ich habe mein wecker nicht schlafe ich
hab einfach coole schule ist unnötig ich
kann so lange wir das geht heute endlich
weiter mit ab ins kloster ich habe lange
auf sich warten lassen ich weiß hat
sorry das letzte ab ins kloster video
kam vor vier wochen da haben wir uns mit
andrea beschäftigt 18 arbeitslos die
über sich selbst sagt dass sie perfekt
ist heute und heute gehts weiter
wir haben heute leute wären wir uns mit
den beiden mädels beschäftigen die mit
andrea im kloster sind das ist einmal
celine und dass es einmal antonia und
die beiden sind auch wirklich vorzeige
kinder leute wie ihr gleich sehen werdet
werden auf den buggy mit kabel eins am
start leute der wie folgt aussieht ich
darf die sendung einfach los hier auf
youtube und die geben jetzt macht er das
einzige was ich sagen muss ist wann die
sendung läuft deswegen jetzt hier die
läuft jeden donnerstag um 20 15 leute
und jetzt schauen wir mal rein und
schauen uns mal will ihn an
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
das ist also selina was ist das für eine
lach alter sieht ist ich will nicht das
böse wort sagen sie aha
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
eine gefriertruhe was sofort ins kloster
aber mal sofort also ganz ehrlich wenn
ich mitarbeite sind örtlichen all dies
wäre und ich mache meine schicht gerade
zu ende es ist 20 uhr lag gleich zu ich
will einfach nur nach hause zu meinen
kindern liegt celine 16 in der
tiefkühltruhe dicker nase raus
okay okay okay also sie ist er hat ihre
karriere obwohl auch schon durchgeplant
erster schritt schule ist unnötig das
der erste schritt in jeder karriere
leute wie wir wissen es alle bill gates
hat sein studium abgebrochen
insofern ist für mich ganz klar ich muss
wirklich allen helfern die es vielleicht
da draußen jetzt schon gibt von céline
sagen leute zilin wird das nächste
microsoft gründen noch ganz kurz ein
ernst gemeinter rat von mir also ich
fand schule früher auch schlimm aber ich
bin mittlerweile froh dass in der schule
war ich doch paar sachen gelernt habe du
hast recht ihn als gut leute leute ich
hoffe ich hoffe ihr habt so wie ich euch
einen notizblock ihre leute
ich muss mich entschuldigen ich habe bis
dato noch nicht mitgeschrieben ich werde
jetzt sofort anfangen mitzuschreiben
leute alles klar so schule ist unnötig
gründe warum manche in die schule geht
der weg hat nicht geklingelt
man hat keine lust braucht die noch mehr
gründe leute braucht ihr ganz ehrlich
noch mehr gründe
er will einfach in seinem eigenen bett
zu sitzen mit einem adidas pulli mit dem
smiley kissen oder links im hintergrund
ja vergessen wir nicht dass miley kissen
weil dieser ganzen sache hier leute und
einfach mit 16 zu sagen ich kann alles
schule ist unnötig ich werd putzfrau
sie kann einfach alles
sie kann alles leute ihre autos
repariert werden fraktion 16
nuklearreaktor ist kaputt und ihr
braucht eigentlich ein nuklear physiker
frank zilin
sie kann alles also ich sags ihr könnt
natürlich auch nur klassiker 14.000 euro
am tag bezahlen aber auch wo der
[Musik]
wasserstoff jährige aber das müsst ihr
einfach alles mal sacken lassen
sie ist eine sehr dominante sehr
dominante person ja ok ja sie ist auch
sehr selbstbewusst muss das ist nicht
mal faktisch falsch was sie da gerade
gesagt hat er mit 16 jahren als person
die nicht mehr zur schule geht und
vielleicht sich noch an das einmaleins
erinnert dann zu sagen ich kann alles
das ist schon selbstbewusst
und davon abgesehen ist natürlich auch
ein sehr förderliche charakterzug wenn
man dominantes leute ganz ehrlich was
würdet ihr machen stellt euch vor ihr
leitet die grösste bank weltweit die
leute die grösste bank weil die seit
geschäftsführer habt mich dass ich im
alltag verdient millionen und dann kommt
zerlin rein und sagt stelldichein sagst
du nie vergisst du kannst nichts sagt
sie ich kann alles
ständig jetzt ein dann holst du aber so
was von den arbeitsvertrag
[Musik]
ok also singen zählt schon mal nicht zu
alles dazu was wir das im moment moment
nur leidlich kann ich kann das nicht das
ist das ist zu viel last auf meinen
schultern es ist wirklich zu viel last
auf meinen sie 16 jahre alt wird gefragt
wann sie alkohol trinkt und leute was
wird normalerweise menschen antworten ja
also sehr disziplinierte menschen ja
also höchstens einmal im monat für
meinen sport durchziehen
leute die schon ein bisschen die spieler
sind aber bisschen entspannt auch zur
einmal zwei wochen leute die gut feiern
gehen jede woche alkoholiker ja so jeden
tag zwei stunden aber sonst eigentlich
nicht zählen 16 immer immer sie wacht
morgens auf wird direkt am anfang
dann bin ich fast nur privat ganz wisst
ihr was das schwerste für mich jetzt
gerade erst leute wisst ihr warum das so
ein emotionaler stress für mich dass
einerseits weil die aussage natürlich in
als extrem am 17
andererseits weil wir vielleicht wisst
ich eine kleine schwester über die 15
besten
wird dieses jahr 16 das heißt im
dezember diesen jahres ist meine kleine
schwester tabea dann so alt wie celine
mein kopf denkt sich oder was würdest du
machen wenn die kleine schwester so was
machen würde man da beginnt der spaß
macht das schon
[Gelächter]
also ganz konsequent von ihr wäre jetzt
wenn sie gesagt hatte alle ich hoffe
einfach alle zigaretten fragt nicht so
blöd wie viele alle fragen sich was für
saft kein mensch mehr auf der welt kann
zigaretten rauchen weil alle zu ziehen
gehen das wäre das wäre konsequent
gewesen
sie sagen wir so los also ich hab ja
kann ich mal der stelle wo ich sage
heute ich habe ja früher auch mal
geraucht so macht das wirklich nicht
leute es ist manchmal fängt manchmal an
damit wenn man denkt man ist cool damit
und dann hat man uns die ganze an der
backe und dann ist es so schwer dass
loszuwerden das ist schlecht für die
eigene gesundheit
es ist teuer aber ich musste auch zur
einordnung sagen zehn oder 15 zigaretten
am tag das ist eine halbe schachtel das
ist nicht wenig aber es ist auch nicht
viel
meine meinung also wenn man umgeben ist
von leuten die wirklich da am start sind
die raucher anderthalb also am tag das
ist schon geist kann viel aber das gibt
dann bin ich dadurch ist auf einem sehr
geringen niveau aber ich bin tatsächlich
überrascht von berlin
ich dachte es würde alles gehört schauen
wir nur so viele
fini einfach viel niedriger du bist 16
1000% hast du nicht mal und lappen nicht
mal für begleitetes fahren du dürftest
nicht mal mit deinem vater jetzt noch
nicht verraten
du kannst meine nerven leute meine
nerven am arsch es ist wirklich zu krank
leute erinnert ihr euch noch an die
folge vor vier wochen andrea dachte ich
sei so die schlimmste im bunde und alle
anderen so eigentlich lieb aus rum aber
brudereck ich hätte mir erstmal die
vorstellung von den anderen reihen
ziehen soll ich weiß auch nicht ich habe
mir die kommentare was ihr davon haltet
also ganz ehrlich
ihr findet hier ein für euch persönlich
vorgeschlagen das video leute meinen
youtube-kanal müssen an dieser stelle
alle von euch abonnieren die noch nie
besoffen gedriftet haben ich bin an der
stelle raus macht's gut